since 1984 Wes Craven's at Nightmare on
Elm Street has sent shockwaves through
pop culture mostly thanks to the
unkillable psycho villain Freddy Krueger
but who was the man behind the makeup
wielding that nightmarish cloth
his name is Robert Englund and he's done
much more than just play a quick child
killer in increasingly cheesy horror
movies in real life England is a
respected character actor and he's been
keeping busy since his last turn in the
role in Freddy vs. Jason here's
everything you need to know about the
man behind the monster who haunts your
dreams horror never ends as Freddy
Krueger England's very face became
synonymous with the horror genre to this
day he still lands roles in horror
movies around the globe with a new
project the puppet based thriller
abruptio expected for release in 2019
after doing more than 75 movies in his
career he estimates at least 20 of them
are horror while it's been nearly two
decades since he's suited up as Freddy
genre projects are always there for him
when he needs a quick paving speaking in
a 2013 interview with the Chicago area
Daily Herald
he said when things get slow for me in
Hollywood I can always go off to Europe
and do a movie in Italy or Spain this is
the great gift the happy accident of my
career because horror movies like
science fiction and action and fantasy
movies speak the international language
of cinema of course that kind of
attitude means that some movies England
has shown up in have been less than
stellar he's open about the fact that
he'll sometimes take jobs just for the
paycheck if you thought he signed on to
strippers versus werewolves for artistic
reasons well think again gamer dreams
England did more than just voice acts
for 2010's call of duty black ops for a
bonus mode of that game he also showed
up as himself teaming up with Danny
Trejo Sarah Michelle Gellar and Michael
Rooker he appeared as a playable
character in a zombie themed level named
Call of the Dead and insane interactive
love letters a horror cinema the level
is a treat for fans of the genre who
also happened to like playing
first-person shooters watch out zombies
I'm coming for you
England's favorite part about the role
was the reaction he received from the
children and his family too young to
remember Freddy Krueger at the height of
his powers
Freddy's kind of old to them is sort of
old-school
to them you know and now that you know
uncle Robert is is working on a Call of
Duty you know he's cool again
con jobs some actors grow to resent the
fandoms that pop up around the most
famous characters but if England has any
frustration with being associated with
Freddie he doesn't show it as he puts it
Freddie will get top billing in my
obituary instead he makes an effort to
meet fans whenever he's able
particularly around the lucrative
Halloween season for years England has
generally done three or four appearances
a year summit comic-con style
conventions and summit specific
screenings of Nightmare on Elm Street
movies they're good occasions to meet
the man behind the makeup posed for a
photo or get something signed in the
movies messages from Freddie were
heart-stopping moments that pretended
death you can have a lot more fun with a
nice autograph
Freddie presents England also stepped
behind the camera starting with a horror
film called 976 evil which was released
in 1988 while he was still making movies
as the dreaded Fred Krueger years later
he also directed the 2008 horror comedy
killer Pat beyond those original
projects England has also taken a
retrospective look at his own career
starring in and helping to produce
nightmares in the makeup chair a
documentary about the long hours of work
it takes to bring Freddy to life through
practical make-up effects in a statement
about the movie England called the doc
my love letter to The Nightmare on Elm
Street series and a practical makeup
children reboot rebuttal
while the quality of each instalment
varies The Nightmare on Elm Street
movies all possess a certain charm
except of course for the 2010 remake
critics were cold - the overly serious
treatment of the material and so was the
actor who made the film's iconic while
he had nothing but kind things to say
about the remix cast England says the
remake missed the mark partly by going
in a much darker direction than series
fans were used to in his opinion the
movie needed a happy-go-lucky element I
think that that ingredient was stepped
on by their reshoots which kind of set
it deeper into the curse of Freddy by
the time that movie began
guest star Robert Englund even though
his most famous role kicked him behind
layers of monstrous makeup England is
still effective as a plane faced
character actor it's work he's kept up
steadily following the end of his
involvement in the nightmare franchise
appearing in shows like Hawaii five-o
Supernatural and Criminal Minds with
guest spots often playing off his
notoriety as the infamous Springwood
slasher while England's personal
nightmare may be over the man of your
dreams is still with us still working
and never too far away from prime time
[Music]